can I um so we we've kind of been
talking about traditional modern I'm
just going to do an experiment three
there's three guys in here right do you
want to protect and provide for your
girl yes or no depends on the girl oh
come on
not by yeah yeah if you want to protect
and provide for your girl yeah do you
want to protect and provide yep there's
three right there but it's like
interesting because I'm asking you guys
more traditional questions and the
answers don't line up so like I honestly
think there's more traditional men than
traditional women nowadays I think the
shortage is an RN not theirs I think
there's a lot of men that want to
protect and provide but like who are
they going to protect and provide for
women that don't listen to them why
would you protect him and that's why it
doesn't listen